Damien Louvet nous retrouvons maintenant
en direct de Pau en Béarn au Palais des
Congrès François Bayrou bonsoir avant
d'évoquer avec vous les élections
municipales en commentaire peut-être sur
ce qu'on a appris de la situation
d'Ingrid Betancourt qui sait gravement
détérioré
vous avez entendu son fils et nous
l'avons tous entendu il y a une
inquiétude qui est une inquiétude
immense et qui doit être désormais prise
en charge par l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale on peut pas
accepter une telle barbarie avec une
guérilla prétenton qui s'acharne sur une
sur une femme et qui l'a conduit aux
portes de la mort sans que personne ne
puisse les forcer à la rendre et on
parle de cette guérilla avec indulgence
comme s'il s'agissait d'interlocuteurs
normaux le président Sarkozy se dit prêt
à aller la chercher c'est une bonne idée
si ça peut faire avancer les choses je
la prouverai il y a vous le voyez bien
une responsabilité que tout le monde
doit assumer et si Nicolas Sarkozy a le
sentiment que ainsi il peut débloquer la
situation des grilles de Bettencourt
très bien qu'il le fasse et tout le
monde la prouvera et tout le monde le
soutiendra mais vous voyez bien que si
les phares poussent cette jeune femme
jusque à l'extrémité de sa vie il faudra
qu'ils en rendent compte devant
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale il y a des indulgences
qui sont coupables alors j'espère que
les choses vont se débloquer que tout le
monde va s'y mettre de quelques pays que
l'on soit François si vous voulez bien
la situation
comment trouvez-vous j'allais dire le
climat politique du pays vous le trouvez
morose inquiet ou après tout ma foi les
choses ne vont pas si mal puisque les
les sondages à l'égard de François
Fillon sont plutôt bons
ce qui domine c'est une immense
désillusion
je la mesure tous les jours comme tous
ceux qui se présentent aux élections
municipales porte-à-porte c'est une
immense désillusion parce que il y a eu
des promesses qui étaient flambantes qui
étaient
mirobolante et évidemment ses promesses
ne pouvaient pas être respectées et sur
un point essentiel qui est les fins de
mois il se trouve que oui le pour enfin
on dit le pouvoir d'achat c'est une
expression un peu abstraite c'est pas de
pouvoir d'achat qu'il s'agit en fait
c'est de pouvoir finir le moi de trouver
que les produits de première nécessité
augmentent de plus en plus et pour des
catégories sociales qui sont de grandes
victimes je pense aux personnes âgées
aux retraites je pense aux femmes qui
élèvent seules des enfants il y a là ce
qui était une classe moyenne française
et qui se trouve aujourd'hui tirée vers
le bas asphyxier et vous savez Françoise
les ajustements à la fin du mois se font
aujourd'hui sur la nourriture sur
l'alimentaire et bien la France ne
devrait pas être un pays qui vit et
accepte que tant et tant de familles et
de personnes seules se trouvent dans
cette difficulté-là avec
quelques centaines d'euros et
l'impossibilité d'arriver à la fin du
mois en équilibre François
avec la gauche à Bordeaux c'est plutôt
avec la droite à Paris on sait pas bien
comment ça va se passer au deuxième tour
parce que le modem va une stratégie un
peu trop compliqué
non c'est c'est vous qui voyez gauche et
droite nous au mouvement de démocrate
quelle est au fond notre mission notre
mission c'est d'ouvrir d'offrir un
nouveau choix aux Français vous avez vu
l'image qu'on vient de voir à l'instant
Bertrand Delanoë avec Lionel Jospin et
bien si le climat de désillusion dans
lequel on vit n'offre aux Français que
le choix de revenir au PS version Jospin
mais il y a là quelque chose au fond
d'absolument désespérant pour les gens
il faut un choix qui permette de dire il
y a des choses qui ne vont pas et en
même temps nous voulons une nouvelle
manière d'affronter la politique et
d'assumer les responsabilités alors vous
dites gauche et droite c'est pas vrai
que nous avons ça n'est pas avec la
droite que nous avons choisie de faire
une entente à Bordeaux c'est avec Alain
Juppé parce que nous considérons qu'il
est un bon maire et Dijon ou à
Montpellier nous avons choisi homme et
femme qui sont des mers que nous
considérons comme estimable c'est une
nouveauté dans la vie politique
française qui y a un mouvement qui dise
on est plus prisonnier des anciennes
frontières on peut travailler avec des
républicains quel que soit leur
étiquette parce que une ville c'est tout
le monde tous les grands courants et
sensibilité qu'il a représentent et
c'est une révolution je vous l'accorde
merci François Bayrou je rappelle donc
que vous exprimer en direct de Pau le
président